thank you for joining us we begin this
NewsHour with Israel continuing to
launch airstrikes on Gaza which has
destroyed residential buildings in Khan
Eunice there was a barrage of Rocket
fire from Palestinian factions towards
Israel in the early hours of Thursday
morning which after a brief pause have
continued in the past two hours the
latest attacks have killed at least
three Palestinians bringing the death
toll to 27 in this recent escalation
Palestinian media say most of the
victims are women and children a funeral
has been held in Gaza for a senior
commander of the Islamic Jihad movement
who was killed in last night's Israeli
airstrikes Ali Hassan Gali was a member
of the military Council and head of the
rocket unit in the alcoots brigades well
we have three correspondents across this
story this R Mohamed Jam Jun is in West
Jerusalem and he'll tell us about the
prospects of a ceasefire villain Marx is
in the southern Israeli city of Ashkelon
but first we go to yumnal side who's in
Gaza City you know they've been new
airstrikes on Gaza in the last hour
yes Foley will Israeli airstrikes have
and stopped actually taking part in
different areas in Gaza again again most
airstrikes are in the northern part and
in the southern part both in hanones and
rabba in the northern part in uh
beitelahia and Beth hanoon now these are
these uh parts are very adjacent to the
borders uh on veteran and bet lahia and
so the Israel airstrikes have continued
to pound these areas for several hours
this day
the airstrikes you say have hit Northern
parts of Gaza Gaza of course is a
densely populated area and despite
Israel saying that it's targeting
Islamic Jihad positions I imagine that
civilians are also being targeted in
these strikes
it's true I mean with the airstrikes uh
and the the the rockets that are falling
in these different areas uh there is
always a destruction and Casualty is uh
falling from the civilians yes these
past hours at least these past two hours
there hasn't been any casualties but
there have been damages in the civilians
homes uh also before that prior to that
uh one of the airstrikes in bet hanoon
caused some injuries among citizens that
were rushed to hospital
locals say that their injuries weren't
serious injuries but this is how it is
uh in a densely populated territory
every airstrike has a very significant
effect on the residential homes and
building here for the population
the funeral of Ali Gali the Islamic
Jihad commander who was killed in last
night's Israeli airstrikes drew a lot of
people
how are these uh killings I mean it's
now the fourth Islamic Jihad member to
be killed by Israel how is it affecting
the group and how are they going to
respond
well yes uh Folly uh while he uh right
after the killing of Ali rally there was
a launching of rockets just an instant
launching of rockets but then it has
been a kosher skull about a couple of
hours ago
when he was buried there was a resuming
to uh the launching of rockets but it
was not like yesterday uh the launching
uh by the Palestinian factions here it
has been very uh very little but many
are artillery shells have been fired
towards uh the Karim Abu Salem Crossing
from the Israeli side and and so it has
been on mortar shells mainly but now uh
uh Palestinian Islamic Jihad faction
here in Gaza have stated that they are
going to be responding to the
assassination of the Ali rally in
particular they said that they're in
preparation and their response should
not be delayed so we're still expecting
to witness more launching of rockets
we're expecting a certain amount and
kind of retaliation for his killing Yuma
thank you very much for that update
you're not outside live there in Gaza
City let's go to villain marks now who's
in Asheville or near the border with
Gaza in southern Israel tell us about
what you've been seeing and hearing on
that side of the Border villain
or fully in the last 15 or 20 minutes
we've seen at least one attempted
interception by the Iron Dome defense
mechanism the Israeli military operates
just probably about a kilometer further
behind us seemingly therefore trying to
intercept a rocket coming from Gaza
we've heard some much deeper uh boom
sounding like artillery or potentially
air strikes slightly further down
towards the coastline from here inside
Gaza as well one assumes and here people
remain on high alert earlier this
morning we did see people outside
businesses were open cafes things like
that people walking the streets there is
still traffic on local roads but there
have been Sirens sounding in smaller
communities near here as well as a few
kilometers down south from here the town
of sterot so clearly these Rockets being
fired from Gaza are having an impact the
Israeli military talking about the
potential according to Israeli media for
reserves to be called up for recruitment
around this area here in Gaza to try and
strengthen what they call security
coordination efforts Folly okay Willem
thank you for update villain marks live
in Ashkelon Mohammed jamjun is joining
us now from West Jerusalem Muhammad
we've heard talk of course about this
possible ceasefire but given the latest
developments and these continued
airstrikes on Gaza it's difficult to see
how the ceasefire is like likely to
happen anytime soon
foreign
it certainly does look as though based
on what we're seeing when it comes to
rockets and and attacks it certainly
doesn't look like a ceasefire is going
to happen anytime soon but there's a lot
of complicated negotiations going on
behind the scenes the conventional
wisdom here is that the Israeli
government is still open to a ceasefire
that they are still talking to Egyptian
mediators uh but that there is a
sticking point the sticking point we
understand is that Islamic Jihad wants a
commitment from Israel that if there is
to be a ceasefire that the Israeli
military will not Target any more
leaders of Islamic Jihad for
assassination of course over the course
of the past two days
we've seen four top commanders of
Islamic Jihad assassinated by Israel in
the Gaza Strip Israel is not willing to
make that concession now last we heard
from the Prime Minister from Benjamin
Netanyahu was last night that was after
he had a meeting a situational
assessment with the defense minister
joov Gallant as well as other members of
his security cabinet he came out he made
it clear that Israel was going to be the
deciding party whether it comes to
escalation or de-escalation so yes it is
certainly looking like a ceasefire might
be further off than we had initially
assumed last night but based on the
comments that are being made a lot of
them unnamed but officials uh high up in
the Israeli government to Israeli media
based on the comments that we're seeing
they do want a ceasefire to come into
effect it's just that it's very
complicated because of the demands on
both sides and really right now it's
going to be crucial hours the hours
ahead as to whether there is further
escalation whether that widens how many
groups may be participating but it does
seem clear that Israel does want to
ceasefire it just at this point really
there's no way to tell when that might
happen Foley thank you very much for
that Mama Jam June live there in West
Jerusalem